our voicemail number is 2192 David P you
can call anytime and ask about anything
here is a really interesting question
that relates directly to what I was just
saying about the voters of Georgia
hi David it's James I just wanted to
know um how do you feel about voter
shaming I know that um
you know
uh a couple things uh Kyle and Mike
figuerado and a few other people I think
um
for The Young Turks are generally
against voter shaming like they don't
criticize Trump voters because they
voted for Trump
um but they'll sometimes criticize
people who voted for Trump because of
the wall or because
of you know the fact that he said
Banning banned Muslims or you know
Mexicans or rapists and all that how do
you feel about votership do you think
it's productive do you think it's fair
um or do you think it's better to just
stick to criticizing the politicians
um
what do you know because uh I I
basically I I want to find out the best
way okay yes right so what's so so
listen there's two things going on here
all right if you're asking me do I think
it's in bounds so to speak for on
programs like mine to be very Frank and
candid and direct about the fact that
there's a lot of dumb people in this
country and many of them don't know what
the hell is going on and they're just
Bamboozled by these politicians with
obvious lies and they fall for it and
they vote for them and how do they even
put their pants on in the morning how do
you balance a checkbook
if you are so ignorant about just basic
things you're being lied to on I have no
problem as a commentary on this program
saying stuff like that and in fact I've
said there's really three main groups of
trump voters there are people who just
don't know what the hell is going on
they don't know they don't know what
Trump policies are they just don't know
anything and they were kind of like
tricked they stumbled into voting for
Trump
there's people who are what we might
call like bad people they do understand
the Trump policy and they understand all
of the things that happen as a result
and all the people that Trump policy is
terrible for and they say I like it and
I'm going to vote for him anyway
and then you've got the third Group
which is people who vote for Trump out
of some selfish
priority well yeah I understand exactly
who and what Trump is but his tax plan
would save me money so I'm going to vote
for him those are the main three groups
of trump voters I've been totally
upfront about that so I have no issue
about shows like mine doing that on the
other hand
I am aware
that as a matter of pragmatics
and effectively deprogramming people
from for example trumpism
if I were running a campaign
right and I was Trump's opponent
I don't think that shaming Trump voters
would be the right way to win them over
right I would take an approach that
would be something more like listen
I understand that because we have so
much work to do in this country to
really make it what it could be
I understand the desire when something
different pops up and Trump was
different
to find in that a reflection of your own
desires about the reality that this
could be a better country I understand
that but we tried it and it failed
and I can tell you exactly what would
make this country better and it's what
I'm offering and I welcome you to come
to me no matter who you voted for last
time around that framing which is you're
not shaming anybody you're actually
saying I get what was going on that made
you say I don't know this is different
maybe it's better
that is more effective than saying
there's a lot of stupid people here
there are a lot of stupid people here
and for a program like mine it's
different than if you're running a
national campaign so that's my view on
voter shaming I hope I'm sort of
explaining it clearly we have a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com and I will see you on the
bonus show